i feel like i'm going to be so much
worse than you at 30. i'm going to be
like [ __ ] awful to hang out with
is it true that like your entire view on
everything just changes the moment you
hit 30. because that's all i've been
hearing
is it true you become a [ __ ] boomer
[Laughter]
i mean start hating every young person
no because like i've heard from so many
people
who are now in their 30s where like it's
literally
i don't know if i identify as a 30 year
old
it's like like a dust start falling when
it's like i don't know if it's like
placebo or whatever
all the way you just like overthink it
but like so many people are like yeah
the moment i hit 30
it's just like everything like i just
stopped giving a [ __ ] about so much when
i feel
30. i i i'm the opposite i don't feel 30
at all
honestly i i don't feel like i've
changed [ __ ]
i just i wonder how you can do like like
i don't know i feel like i'm struggling
to keep up sometimes when people want to
party and i'm
you know i'm all right fine i'll come no
i'm right there as well and i'm like
well i'll force myself to drink but half
the time i'm like my heart's not in it
you know
yeah my heart's not there you know i'm
still up there like my god
i'm i'm i'm like always in bed by like
three now and gaunt would be like yeah i
stayed up until 9 a.m and i started just
doing work at the time
it's like 11 30.
yeah i don't know like um i don't feel
like i've changed at all
i'm almost 31 now and i feel like i just
like i i feel like i'm
i feel like i'm still [ __ ] 25 23 i
don't know i mean you still look 25
you're gonna be you're gonna be like
that [ __ ]
old anime character that's like the most
fun to hang out with and he teaches you
some cool [ __ ] and then he sacrifices
himself casually later on you're gonna
be the old man who like looks really
small but the moment he takes the shirt
off it's
jacked that's right basically i mean i
mean from what i've heard from just
other people who are ordering me they've
just told me that
third your 30s is just basically your
20s with one debuff to your body
and i i i i i guess my hangovers
what's the debuff for you i i guess my
hangovers are slightly worse now that's
that's the only reason like
the only reason like i've i drink a [ __ ]
ton more wine now because i don't know
what it is
like it's funny right because when i was
when i was like eighteen to like
twenty thirty you go you like beer vodka
nah me
moment you turn thirty i have a wine
cooler yeah and it's fully you know
that was exactly me when i was thirty i
was like yes i
i only drink wine now thank you very
much beer get
get that teenage [ __ ] out the next step
is going to be like wine
cognac
yeah i don't know like i just i mean i
drink wine because one i like the taste
and two because
for some reason the hangovers for wine
are just like
seriously terrible i was like i remember
because like yeah exactly like when i
was in my teens in like early 20s i was
like
why and [ __ ] you i would get the worst
hangovers on wine especially
red wine like i i swear i had like
[ __ ] vietnam flashbacks from drinking
red wine at university right
thai man
like the hangovers there were like
[ __ ] unbearable and then i hit like
27 and i'm like oh this uh this this
kind of feels warm
i don't even have those like nam
flashbacks because like i didn't even
like
i didn't even drink water making that a
thing
i didn't because i didn't even i wasn't
even interested in drinking wine i i
like you know in my early 20s because my
dad was like a [ __ ] heavy wine
drinker so he's always like you know try
this nice red wine
yeah absolutely this is a great wine now
you know now that i can drink wine it's
like oh yeah that's [ __ ] fantastic
but
you know when you're like 21 22 and you
drink a glass of red you're like
oh god like i cannot get used to this at
all maybe we'd drink more wine if we
grew it in the uk but unfortunately i
think the only place they make wine in
uk are prison so i don't really think
that much choice
i think uk does make some wine is that
why is that considered wine or is that
just like grape juice
attitude
as well you just get it from france
right so why don't you make your own
when everyone's gonna be like we
literally have friends like
yeah exactly i mean i didn't realize how
lucky i had it until i moved to a
country that
you know is not well i mean they produce
sake here they do produce wine but it's
not
as well known i didn't know how good we
had it there where you can just go to a
[ __ ] local co-op or tesco's and buy
great wine that is like tripled the
price here in japan
yeah yeah yeah why sucks here yeah
that's the problem right
you have to go to like a specialist wine
praise because like if you go to [ __ ]
family mart or seven it's it's like
you're just basically picking poison if
you drink a cheap wine here
you know it's it's basically just it's
basically just bottled rat boys
we have such first world problems
we're just like concerned about the
quality of the wine that we've had
listen what happened to us man oh no man
well i didn't it's i
i would say i'd start drinking way more
wine because of um because of corona
because you know when you're stuck
inside you you got to fight you've got
to find an interest you've got to make
your own fun
this is like a narrator it's like god
decided to take up a new hobby
alcoholism